hey yo what up its your boy leaked to
the pot why do I do that so racist
hey how's it going bros - beautiful
today we're gonna play some more message
aren't you excited
are you going to finish this episode I
mean you got this [ __ ] far this is a
really good game I really enjoy it it's
really good fun I'm a huge fan of the
first game in fact Kjus I haven't said
that a million times already
probably should have started this video
when the loading screen was done but hey
you make mistakes in life and you just
have to keep talking throughout them cuz
that way Jesse it worked
plastic five my favorite divisions yet I
can't reach em on the beat oh yeah I got
a five star on this map yeah why is this
my problem faith more like no fast
sorry good one
cool look at this this is awesome yeah I
don't care where am I supposed to go
find Icarus alright let's set a waypoint
and we'll just [ __ ] walk this
direction alright so touch up on the
story we basically sold this disc that
we want to post still I'm getting shot
guys [ __ ] off and then what happened was
I got this hooker thing and now we had a
depth ooze it's Asian guy and he's like
going [ __ ] up this building it was
pretty [ __ ] epic and now we should
give it to him and then we're done this
is it Fly Trap let's go
a pop one right in your breasts
Santacruz sorry I think he's nearby what
is happening why absolutely thanks for
the really enjoy the last level it was
so [ __ ] cool I really actually want
to just [ __ ] play it again blowing up
this entire building and never on a
crane look at that
nailed it are we going for it Wow
you didn't even know that was gonna
happen faith don't even [ __ ] joke
that could have been like nails and [ __ ]
underneath how do you you crazy son of
our faith anybody how you doing never
thought I'd say that I hate him you sure
are a sight for sore eyes babe what
happened here
don't ask and stay away from the fence
it packs quite a punch
don't ass end up like those guys when
wish guys help getting out of here
shutting down the electricity should do
it or I just leave for Kruger sector for
me or that
though I'd prefer my suggestion please
Oh what do I do
those cables should lead you to the
switch which keep oh sure
don't go anywhere funny uh okay so this
guy is an [ __ ] that's right I spit on
you and now we're following the cables
whoa I did a back roll you can do the
app ah ah ah what happened
alright don't touch the [ __ ] cable
Sam yeah we're doing it
Oh slide down just like you slide on
that oh my god one hand baby you
straight up cray cray [ __ ] you door
going through here of course she knew
this cuz the cables were here right lice
you're liar faith I'm surprised you
haven't been chased by that that hasn't
been much like military interactions so
far which is kind of nice
a lot of people seem really pissed about
the fact that you can't use a gun in the
game and I was originally as well I was
like what the [ __ ] I enjoyed that but
once you think about it really it was
kind of lame how you could just shoot
everyone I like that was the best way to
deal with it in the first game this kind
of [ __ ] go berserk on everyone when
really faith is a character that is
supposed to be of a hay boat supposed to
be about [ __ ] Park orange books
that's what she does just randomly
jumping on [ __ ] I can't stop her it
ain't even me doing a rats how you doing
alright here's the [ __ ] cables we're
gonna see the rat get electrocuted I
remember this
nevermind I'm [ __ ] chair dun dun
you owe me one I know look at this guy's
love that jump oh so sexy
keep going pip I really hope the story
picks up cuz honestly I don't [ __ ]
understand [ __ ] Hey look at my face come
on like it looks so good when you look
down here no I'm a reflection man I
don't know crap faith all those Krueger
SEC they're headed toward the lair oh
there we go remember I said about
military interaction it's about to
happen
no say something getting dizzy second
jamming us let's go back they be there
good talk
are you telling an elevator to go faster
hey I'm fifth I am in a hurry that event
that bet sorry sorry did I ruin dramatic
where are you
they shouldn't have [ __ ] with sugar
sack
hang in there we're coming
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] got real y'all
oh my god the [ __ ] was that Sam what
they got all the drones and [ __ ] please
just go to that ow
Meredith we gotta head back is that it
the same thing I don't even know what
we're doing
oh [ __ ] everyone's gonna be gone so it
is a pretty cool
they all died I knew it I'm like with a
[ __ ] all these guys
Oh your dad on you oh no no one no no
aah
no I'm here my until several be told
hovering about feet is quiet too quiet
they got it
okay so Kruger sec is this bad company
that we're not supposed to talk like
that we kind of [ __ ] up now they took
our leader with a cyber space helicopter
oh we got to defeat them now look at
them are they seriously on guard right
now oh come on
hahaha oh man it's so fun to [ __ ]
punch them and [ __ ]
alright watch this then Oh [ __ ]
Oh God whew close call nice we'll do
this oh [ __ ] dog that was sick
ah come on there's 400 that's I was 7
feet [ __ ] yeah now that's what I'm
talking about
alright we got to stop that elevator did
I just call a helicopter an elevator yes
I did thank you very much for supporting
me come on there's a new one class
hunter
all right can't be that bad can't be
that bad oh don't mind me just hanging
around all she's got so much help
surprise [ __ ] I missed ya keep
jumping up the stairs see dumb [ __ ] oh
why did I break your helmet Oh
i'ma break your balls too you ain't [ __ ]
man
[ __ ] you holy [ __ ] faith you're a badass
that's what I'm talkin about whoa did I
just kill like 40 people yes I did I
figured we could ask some questions I
don't know take a [ __ ] in his mouth
borders with a capture the presided was
that weird oh shoot they wouldn't submit
especially they all got run I'll meet
you later oh no not the drones what the
[ __ ] oh we gotta escape now okay I've
gotta go fast I suppose
go fast go face oh that's fast that's so
fast
you're right should have thought of that
um doesn't it make sense if the
government use it like these different
polish that doesn't kill you or whatever
to just seem like that kind of society
I'm just saying and it would explain why
we keep getting shot but we're still
fine like babe you've been shot like 100
million times
doesn't that bother you in video games
when the main character keeps getting
shot and you're like well I mean he'd be
dead by now kind of like when you play
Uncharted and you get hey guys sorry I
was just talking to my press
when you play I'm charted an eight keeps
getting shot and you're like well HP
Nate be dead by now just me okay well
cool then I'm sorry I'll never open my
mouth again except hey buddy how you
doing I want to get powders broke my
legs I know where to go give me the
construction crane in downtown south and
I'll explain all right so what happened
first of all
excuse me very much but I do believe I
got myself an upgrade randomly how do we
go to the rep right there radius now I
think I should be upgrading combat and
[ __ ] but I don't really think the
[ __ ] point
all right gear no all right movement we
can definitely do so double wall run
I'm sure that's really good focus shield
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
extended slide I like sliding but I
think we should go with their pipes and
ladder faster that shit's annoying yow
and then we should go with a double wall
run so wall run yeah that's a really
good mood and then why not get in it all
right you know what Pappas got the whole
bag oh never mind how about any of this
stamina [ __ ] it you know what [ __ ] comet
it's like this game being done by a poor
combat it's about love all right it's
about love and friendship and running
you know what I mean you know what I
mean exactly what I mean you know all
about that love and friendship and
running you never run a day in your life
happy that's okay I'm not judging
hundred percent judging you right now by
the way all right let's [ __ ] this guy's
up you know what [ __ ] y'all yeah that's
right I said it
you all can suck
my face dance I can do that move twice
yeah a [ __ ] y'all
you don't [ __ ] with faith [ __ ] I'm fake
y'all know my name
oh [ __ ] more of them fate Oh shitty
space went through the wall oh come on
man oh come on come on me where am I
going
this is it oh my god I finally made it
god damn there's Jade 1jo bumps nope
nope you can suck it us mr. krüger gang
leader came to like himself bigger is
are you seeing this
wait no one got killed no nope I talked
to Rebecca thing and she's offering us
sanctuary No
Noah didn't trust Rebecca I justify us
at least change
but I'm not staying long
what's happening with the cranes that
were jumping cranes oh me oh my watch it
damn I bet you $1,000,000 Noah's not
dead all right if you know what died we
would have seen it it would have been
all traumatic and [ __ ] listen if you
don't see him die they did all right
live live and learn from wise and wise
from Porter pies but bad ice yep you
heard it yes which I'd said all right
oh god just slide I was not ready for
sliding but this feels nice on my butt
oh never mind
wow that really [ __ ] hurt man I'll be
oh my god we're going down here that's
cool ah my ass don't roll oh Jesus
opening there this is so much like the
first game I remember this part
do you remember you never played it well
they don't matter
honestly like if you think this game
looks cool you should probably and
haven't play the first one you should
really just buy the first one it's
probably you can probably get it for
like 2 bucks honestly stead of paying 60
for this I mean it's a great game you
can if you really alright whatever
listen it's not your money spend it the
way you want I literally don't I almost
died that's what I care about more
alright pressing another brofist yeah
what happened what I do what I do
I guess we go down here slam that door
what this is a mount what is this
I like the music it's so funky hey buddy
and that makes two take some I shoot it
[ __ ] oh we gotta meet Rebecca she lives
in the sewer the rat that lives in the
sewer
hello mastermind great name dude [ __ ]
awesome hey cool avatars [ __ ] down here
didn't it oh my god she's like a [ __ ]
kangaroo and [ __ ] oh she's pissed she's
like don't touch me [ __ ]
I've seen the news faith I'm sorry no
need to pretend no but I am look Noah
and I may not have seen eye to eye but I
did respect him and your parents no I
said you were part of the same group yes
we were till I realized that there's no
peaceful way we can rid ourselves of the
conglomerate and the families behind it
chef
we've got to destroy arias face I have
ever seen using every weapon at our
disposal I know what you think but
you're wrong I don't have it yeah see I
think you do and that's why Kruger SEC
is hunting you and why they killed Noah
back off yeah back off
I'm sheltering you for now but don't
take my hospitality for granted at some
point I'm gonna ask you to step up or
step out oh no for Becky's made your
point
look all I'm saying is this you're no
longer neutral faith just get some rest
I'm sure you'll understand in time
Tristan will show you your quarters
good old Tristan always trust him to
show in my quarter we'll talk again that
came out wrong he says I need to update
my facebook status
I'm down I got [ __ ] to do not now I need
to finish this
Oh flashbacks who's that in the window
the damn kid get her it's me where's
mommy faith got that fat man back story
yeah cuz there were sisters and this
sister became a cop so they got
separated I guess what is all this
so I guess the cops got her the face
became a run that is an awkwardly close
shot Jesus Christ I wake up fast oh my
god
thank you Xbox for the enemy of my enemy
I appreciate we got another upgrade pump
what are we gonna spend that [ __ ] on the
sewer suck I used to live in this nice
flat but the [ __ ] is this man
it's disgusting it smells like a rat in
here can I make this jump course I can
what do you think I am think you guys
have a little bit of a leakage problem
and I'm not talking about yo a s [ __ ]
sorry let's do this quest you called I
wanted to give you some rest but things
are becoming a bit hairy around here and
we all need to pull our weight
Kruger suck they're moving into the
tunnels setting up some new taiko
stationery since you use this screens
just for wallpaper close for comfort and
those sentry drones need to be dealt
with before they're activated that
someone's under way I'm able to move
around I can help I expected no that's
not a racer keyboards already out there
and again the drones that's awesome I
have the same one so they shouldn't pose
any danger but watch out for cooler SEC
patrols on my way send me the locations
I will do this and we can all breathe a
little easier um I like reading it's
like one of those things I do whoa holy
[ __ ] sorry but that was [ __ ] awesome
oh my god dude that okay alright I guess
back we're back
and it just landed right in your titty
hey Bob I can fall off the ledge that's
right [ __ ] oh it's time to say hello
and goodbye at the same time
dick where am I going now push the
second thing hasn't now oh [ __ ]
only one more and it's done going thanks
appreciate it
hit happen again what the [ __ ] oh my god
alright let's get the last one now and
destroy the final century Gary yeah
best arrival deal it is like a really
honest thing like it is a cool idea like
of these runners passing information and
kind of moving beyond the government's
control it's just like the characters
like I don't care about Noah where the
[ __ ] is nowhere
I don't know why who's no way yo I don't
even say no when Noah went to the other
oh-ah if you know what I mean kill me
please thank you for that should make us
think twice before they come back down
yeah how about you think twice before
max ask me next time it's gonna hurt
didn't even feel it where do I go
alright we can catch uh me being there
as much
all right I'm back girl but most
importantly one in the center yeah we
need an explosion there god damn her
face is scary will be our lure that
ought to keep them scrambling huh yeah
that honor
Satan good to see you you're gonna want
in on this I know her she's Irish
Lightning dude don't officer thanks for
covering up the subtitles officer and
our target for today I'm not an assassin
kill me out we're not killing her we're
grabbing her to trade for prisoners we
should do this faith payback for the
lair I sure what's the plan
what conditioner his face your hotel so
far the location of someone they want
very much me she's gonna lead the strike
team and walk right into our ambush I
need you and Icarus to clear our escape
routes we'll handle that yeah well until
we can strike a tangible blow we don't
have much else that we can do I'm not
sure you can ever win this way Rebecca
and I'm not sure your opinion matters
you oh let's get going the sass man like
it goes left it goes right it goes up it
goes down I don't even know what to say
anymore okay I suppose I'll play some
Hannah strike on this screen it should
be awesome to get around maybe half-life
3 has finally come out in this universe
mmm that is just ridiculous I got a mag
upgrade by looking at my arm it's not
cool pull down yeah that was cool right
I could have could live without it but
hey that was cool right I thought I
could do like the double wall jam thing
but I suppose
all right all right all right we're
going I know nobody no impossible
those extractions need to be clear roll
down yeah [ __ ] the wall bar Rebecca
don't worry we're gonna tear down the
walls I forgot to Jon [ __ ] those things
are programmed to kill damn they got a
lock on me change but I can't move
either you'll have to deactivate them
that's what I do that's my life I'm
faith [ __ ]
yay I'm a strong independent asian
minority woman that's right
that doesn't bother me I've killed
people I [ __ ] kill people I run in
circles - it's pretty cool isn't it hey
ex ah [ __ ] hell cool name dude others
have got to do the pole down yeah wow
that hit my face my beautiful face all
right where are these oh my god oh I'm
so super pissed right now
Krueger no you're welcome but I love
hair hi oh here hey Carissa we're gonna
do this we could split up
take one root each good idea I have a
feeling Rebecca won't accept failure
scary woman she is scary you have cold
places though I have the same ones well
maybe it's time you and I stopped
assuming things about one another maybe
just so you know I'm doing this for no
no offer hey just depends are other
controls disabled the century girl and
what are you waiting for
I thought your runners were supposed to
be fast get a move on sir yes sir I'll
take the B that's ma'am thank you very
much he'll never know what hit him my
shoe that's what it's gonna hit them
I'll text them slam that door yeah
that's right hey look at this pile it
could be a giant underneath here
oh no oh sorry got it sir oh look a face
I miss the city it's been a while
ah need to work on my tan
that is a giant-ass clear
well there
yes we'll go this way oh yeah the
pulldown I love the app Paul [ __ ] the
walls yeah and I died alright well this
has been a great episode having it you
enjoyed yourself didn't you
not too much I hope they would like if
you enjoyed this and let me know if you
want more and I'll see you bros the next
episode is always stay awesome price
this is so crazy
oh my God we're to come from Jesus oh I
see the hole I can see the hole guys oh
my god
Queen slain